so almost since the first day of the
Trump administration we've been
following the lies around so-called
voter fraud voter impersonation and
these three to five million so-called
illegal votes for Hillary Clinton the
Donald Trump asserted existed and of
course there was no evidence for that at
the time there were these kind of vague
stories about people from Massachusetts
being bused up to New Hampshire and this
sort of thing and a voter fraud
commission was actually formed as a
result a ton of money was spent the
voter fraud commission found absolutely
nothing and now we had sarah huckabee
sanders give one of her deranged
gongshow press briefings yesterday and
she was trying to explain how donald
trump has been a uniter rather than a
divider and she ended up blaming
everybody but the Trump administration
for the recent rash of right-wing
violence and hilariously she mentioned
that an overwhelming majority of voters
in November of 2016 voted for Trump
which of course they didn't he lost the
popular vote here is Sarah Huckabee
Sanders making the case herself again I
think the president has had a number of
moments of bringing the country together
once again I'll remind you that the very
first thing the President did was
condemn the attacker and the very first
thing the media did was blame the
president you guys have a huge
responsibility to play in the divisive
nature of this country when 90% of the
coverage of everything this president
does is negative despite the fact that
the country is doing extremely well
despite the fact that the president is
delivering on exactly what he said he
was going to do if elected and he got
elected by an overwhelming majority of
63 million Americans who came out and
supported him and wanted to see his
policies enacted he was elected by the
overwhelming majority of 63 million
Americans who came out and supported him
no he wasn't what is she talking about
it's been normalized so much that it
almost slips by unnoticed but she's
again saying he was supported by a
majority of voters which he was not he
lost the popular vote by millions of
votes to Hillary Clinton and as usual
it's projection the people crying fake
news most often are the ones doing the
spreading of fake knee
most often and it's sort of funny that
they take every position on almost every
issue except here where they're actually
consistent they're consistent only in
their total demonstrable lies and I
don't know how Sarah Huckabee Sanders at
this point Pat looks at herself in the
mirror and decides that she can live
with being the professional liar she has
become its a cartoonish type of lying at
this point and she's not held
accountable yeah totally untrue it's not
like she's just miss speaking there the
overwhelming majority of Americans don't
vote either because they don't want to
or they're not registered or they're not
old enough and the heart of that what
she was saying that wasn't necessarily
majority could she could just be
implying that the plurality of people
voted for Donald Trump also not true 63
million American men vote for Trump but
66 million voted for Hillary Clinton so
maybe she should be president I guess
we've sort of come full circle
right like this was part of Shawn
Spicer's first or second press
conferences White House press secretary
now I don't even remember and then now
it's part of Sarah Huckabee Sanders in
2018 and I don't even know how you
combat this at this point because I've
said you know the reporters in the room
bears some responsibility
I've before stated many times that when
Sarah Huckabee Sanders doesn't answer a
question or answers a question with an
obvious or blatant lie every subsequent
reporter should ask the same question or
demand an answer but she ended the press
briefing right after this question or
answer and I don't know what else
reporters can do you do they just stop
showing up altogether I guess that's an
option but then you end up losing one of
the few opportunities you have to
actually question this administration
about what it's doing but let me go back
to the content of all this she blamed
negative news stories about Trump for
the recent string of right-wing violence
the mag a bomber the synagogue shooter
does that make any sense like why would
negative media stories about Trump cause
pro Trump acts of violence like if she's
saying people were asking for it it's an
incomprehensible argument that's
shockingly even more disturbing than
repeating this lie that
from one the majority of the votes but
it doesn't go away